hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason TV and
today we're talking with Damon rude a
senior editor at reason.com and a
devoted Supreme Court watcher the
Supreme Court is back in session Damon
what are the cases that are particularly
peaking your curiosity this session well
you know the health care case is
obviously the big one and that's one of
the biggest ones in the last few years
and this is about the whether or not the
individual mandate is constitutional and
more than that is what about more than
that so it is the individual mandate
exceed Congress's power under the
Commerce Clause if it does exceed that
power does the whole health care act
have to be struck down or can the
individual mandate be severed from it
there's also a question of is because
this is potentially a tax does that mean
that you can't actually challenge it
until the tax law goes into effect and
the Supreme Court in a kind of
unprecedented move is allowing for days
of oral testimony in the oral argument
three days i think it is basically five
five-and-a-half hours of argument to
devote to all these different questions
basically four separate questions what
what's your sense of things what's going
to happen well I it's it's not clear to
me that there are five votes against the
Health Care Act you know the lot of the
conversation focuses on Justice Kennedy
he's often the fifth both the swing vote
yeah it's not clear to me that even that
the Chief Justice Roberts is going to
vote to strike it down he's seen
hilariously seen as these conservatives
who of course are going to be against
Obamacare but in fact he's typically
Roberts has taken a very broad view of
congressional power of federal power
generally so I could see him voting to
uphold the law I could also see him
voting just very narrowly to maybe to
put it off this tax issue would be a way
that we're just not going to touch it
until basically 2014 that would be a way
to you know to avoid the political you
know Papa tell you what what's next on
your list will the big Arizona
immigration law this is the this is
what's kind of that the papers please
law that the police can basically ask
someone if they think they're
undocumented show your you know cities
what is what's the constitutional issue
there that states should not be
enforcing federal immigration law or not
making federal immigration the issue is
is that immigration is traditionally a
federal matter and the federal
government sets these laws in Arizona's
argument is that the federal government
has you know has not even been
holding up its end of the bargain and so
the states then can step in and pick up
the slack and the the federal government
Kabam administration's argument is that
no this is a federal matter the states
can't do this so it's really it's it's a
kind of a federalism states rights quest
what how do you think it'll play out
because you know the the hardcore
supposedly principled conservatives on
the court have gone every which way it
seems in terms of federalist issues
depending on the outcome that they
decide that yeah there's definitely been
every which way there was a case out of
Arizona in the last couple years a
Chamber of Commerce be whiting and this
had to do with an air is a similar air
grown Arizona immigration law but this
required employers to use e-verify to
check the status and there was there
five votes to uphold that so I think
that we're likely to see a repeat of
that I mean the issues are a little
different this is definitely more
controversial but there's some recent
precedent to say that the courts
conservative the five
conservative-leaning you know justices
are going to say that this is a state
matter let the state do it next case
that you're watching the case one case
I've been I've been watching is uncle
saket versus EPA it's out of Idaho this
is basically the Environmental
Protection Agency issues these things
called administrative compliance orders
it's a command to property owners saying
you can't you know stop building this is
a protected wetland and the issue here
is that these administrative compliance
orders these government commands are not
subject to judicial review so this
family the Sacketts they want to go to
court and say the EPA is wrong this is
not a wetland and we want to build and
they understood the law as it stands now
they can't do that so this is actually a
due process case as well as a property
rights one where the issue is do they
get to have their day in court what how
do you think it'll play out I think it's
going to go in their favor the the oral
arguments not just the conservative
judges who you'd expect to be you know
sympathetic but also Justice Breyer
Justice Ginsburg they express basically
the point of view that you know the
entire American jurisprudence you know
has been trending towards more due
process rights rather than less so why
would this regulatory area why would you
know American citizens suddenly have
less due process rights just in this one
area well Damon rude reason senior
editor talking about the latest session
of the Supreme Court of the United
States thanks for talking thank you for
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie
you